pas très combatif face aux les vernis
les élections demain en iran comme
unique fait voter mais les laïcs
ressources de partie la pollution des
plages une amélioration mais encore des
problèmes
exemple mesdames et messieurs bonsoir le
terrible accident hier soir dans le port
des sables d'olonne a provoqué une
émotion non seulement dans la région
mais dans tout le pays naturellement par
lui-même bien entendu le bilan est
affreux huit victimes dont un enfant
mais aussi parce que les bornes à une
époque où la navigation les anges ont
fait des progrès foudroyants
et elle compte chaque jour de nouveaux
adeptes alors on se pose mille questions
sur la sécurité en réalité il faut bien
voir comment les choses se sont passées
hier les victimes se sont noyées à 400
mètres de la sortie du port leur
embarcation a chaviré ayant été
complètement balayées par un vent d'une
intensité exceptionnelle en vous parlant
du tour de france à la voile
je vous disais hier soir je me rappelle
ici même que l'étape avait été annulée
parce que la mer était de proxy donc les
professionnels pas disons les experts en
navigation n'avait pas osé prendre la
mer hélas leur prudence n'a pas été
suivi par des gens de nantes et de paris
en l'occurrence qui ont accumulé les
imprudences par exemple monsieur min
sans même pas de brassière de sauvetage
j'ai presque envie de parler en l'espèce
d'un suicide comme un air était derrière
des vents violents force 8 et des creux
de quatre mètres
la météo et la vie de coup de vent
étaient affichés au bureau du port et
aux affaires maritimes
neuf personnes arrivées au port de
plaisance des sables pour essayer la
nouvelle vedette un geek watch de 8,60
avec un moteur d'une centaine de chevaux
comme celle ci tous heureux de faire un
tour en mer sans même penser au gilet de
sauvetage
la mise à l'eau s'effectue vers 17
heures le bateau était sur le banc n'ont
pas de sens avec le mieux anglais est
restée là-bas d'ailleurs on l'a déchargé
que la trappiste aux environs de 5 ans
et vous les avez prévenu que le temps se
gâte et telfrance lui élevant manière
fort ceux ci celui comme jeudi
sûrement un peu plus j'avais pas vu
l'état de la mer depuis le matin que
cela est grave et d'ailleurs vous lundi
pour que ça puisse en sortir comme ça
mais c'était pas le seul bateau est
sorti à yann on y avait quelques bateaux
qui sont sortis mais tous les orteils
gelés quoi l'on peut il revenir en route
famille de l'abri de l'acheter puis dans
la becque la vigueur en août comme ils
ont été d'un arbre dangereux et des eaux
font beaucoup de bateaux de pêche sur
glace sont perdus si le nook bien brise
abyan dit-on au sable les guides de
navigation les instructions nautique et
les cartes signale cet endroit dangereux
de plus pour conduire une telle vedette
il faut un permis mer ces plaisanciers
devait donc connaître les risques qu'ils
couraient en commettant cette imprudence
majeur
dharam se produisit très vite à peine 1
milles en mer une ou deux déferlante la
vedette coule sous les yeux d'un
touriste à son balcon qui prévient les
pompiers vers 18h15
dans les dix minutes on était sur place
on a récupéré une victime
mais au fort et on a demandé des
renforts
parce que cette victime nous avait dit
qu'il irait si cette personne encore
dans le fond c'est la personne qui fait
qu'elles mènent exactement de l'arrivée
aussitôt sur place pour récupérer encore
deux autres corps qui floppait on a
ramené aux peurs on est reparti une
troisième fois qu'on a récupéré un but
loin milieu qu'on a ramené et en pologne
avait un bateau un chalutier qui a
ramené un corps aussi et on est reparti
une quatrième fois la relance n'a plus
rien à prouver on a vu des morceaux de
bois 2
du bateau d'autres acteurs mais en
absolument rien trouvé on a patrouillé
jusque vers 8h20 pour 39 en octroyant
pour lui il faire donc on arrêter les
recherches pour la nuit les recherches
ont repris ce matin sans plus de
résultat à l'état de la mer ne
permettant pas la plongée la vedette est
à 8 10 mètres de fond quatre corps sont
sans doute prisonniers à l'intérieur de
sa cabine
l'essor de la navigation de plaisance
vous disais j'ai été si rapide ces
dernières années et les nouveaux
amateurs n'ont pas eu le temps
d'apprendre les règles principales de
sécurité les spécialistes mettent
d'ailleurs en garde tous les amateurs de
plaisance et rappelle ses trains
quand la mer se déchaîne ils vont être
bien entre eux pour avoir une chance d'y
résister sans pouvoir vous donner
naturellement des indications sur tout
ce que vous devez faire avant d'aller
ramer sur l'océan voici une revue de
détail du matériel de stockage du
matériel de première urgence que tout
plaisancier se doit d'avoir à son bain
les gilets de sauvetage bien entendu la
première des choses que je prends que
ces gens n'avaient pas une brêle des
couronnes bout et un gilet de sauvetage
dont je vous redis les avirons
indispensable au cas de panne de moteur
mais dans un une force à huit sa servir
est malheureusement pas grand chose vous
avez des instruments sonores
éventuellement qu'on peut avoir ici
chocolat possibilité de vous montrer mon
mais corne de brume mais on peut avoir
n'importe quel instrument souvent pour
faire du bruit si on est dans le bruit
indispensable un grade main tendue et le
tableau avec la chaîne d'encre
indispensable et fusées rouges se sont
ils et les quelque chose absolument il
faut avoir même si on est pas
complètement en règle avec la sécurité
pour le à partir de demain vendredi une
nouvelle grande vague de départs en
vacances sans doute la plus importante
de dicter ses graphiques que nous
présente bison futé sont simples à lire
demain vendredi 3 août il était
absolument de partir dans la proche
rouge de 15 heures à 18 heures parce que
le trafic sera très chargé et si vous ne
pouvez ne voulait pas non plus de 18h à
21h quant à samedi la zone rouge
celle où l'on vous demande avec
insistance de ne pas prendre la route
elle se situe de 3 heures du matin
jusqu'à 15 heures et vous voyez à gauche
que c'est dans les petites heures de la
nuit entre 3h et 6h la rouge et les
routes que le bruit donc le plus
mais comment se présente la météo pour
les prochains heures par ambre m vous
m'avez l'air assez sympa sans excès un
accès quai laubeuf 8 exact le beau temps
revient il y aura encore des nuages
demain dans le sud est mais je pense
qu'un parti le dimanche il fera très
beau envoyons la carte demain donc des
landes et pyrénées aux alpes d'abord
beaucoup de nuages encore avec encore
des pluies et même des orages mais ces
nuages se décaleront dans la journée
vers le sud-est pour affecter l'après
midi et le soir la corse
il y aura même des éclaircies près du
golfe du lion soto le reste du pays un
temps comme on dit variable c'est-à-dire
avec encore des nuages assez nombreux
des averses même principalement au nord
de la loire mais aussi des éclaircies et
les températures à la faveur des
éclaircies commence par noter samedi
encore plus beau l'amélioration continue
des nuages encore dans de nombreuses
régions mais les pluies affecteront plus
que les régions proches des frontières
du nord et de l'est
ailleurs des brouillards matinaux et
ensuite des éclaircies avec des passages
nuageux je pense que d'immenses une fois
n'est plus beaux et les températures
atteindront à nouveau des sommets que
tout le monde attend et la mer
commencera-t-elle en général
la mère je pense pas se calmer
progressivement mais je pense également
que dimanche il y aura à nouveau sans
doute peut-être des nuages près de la
manche et donc à nouveau un peu devant
l'en tout colle n'attendront pas
certainement les sommets de force de
l'eau des plages où l'on se baigne et
quelquefois douteuses depuis le début
des vacances beaucoup de médecins ont à
soigner les infections diverses dues à
des amis inventent des bactéries
provenant de lots de plage polluée
naturellement il ne s'agit pas de dire
que toutes les plages sont dangereuses
pour la santé des estivants
mais la situation peut se résumer le
nombre encore peu élevé de socialisation
le mans installé sur nos côtes et
l'accroissement très sensible de la
population
mais pendant les périodes de vacances
voilà deux causes de la pollution des
eaux
un reportage de jean jacques dufour à
nice l'été les grandes villes côtières
se remplissent d'estivants qui
remplissent les plages et aussi les
éleveurs et ses égouts se déversent dans
la mer là où justement sommeil les
touristes sans importance quand il
existe une station d'épuration
malheureusement la plupart des cités
méditerranéennes n'en possède pas à nice
mais c'est la même chose à marseille ou
toulon les eaux usées de 400000
personnes c'est-à-dire des leviers de
litres du rin et des tonnes de matières
fécales ont pour destination la
méditerranée après être passé dans cette
station de prétraitement des eaux qui a
déjà le mérite d'exister mais qui
malheureusement ne fait que des chiffres
et des huiles et et écrémer
chaque jour on décharge ainsi
promettre une seconde d'eaux usées entre
9h du matin et midi et entre 14 heures
et 18 heures
loïse et s'en va par là elle va être
projeté à la mer à 460 mètres du rivage
par 80 mètres de profondeur une eau usée
qui contient plusieurs millions de
bactéries par centimètre cube avec la
pollution chimique provenant des usines
et cette pollution bactérienne provenant
des eaux usées voilà deux dangers qui
menacent l'autorun enfin si cet intérêt
se perdre dans l'immensité liquide mais
parfois les vents changent alors on nage
dans les déchets pollutions les endroits
qui ne sont pas vraiment en ont trouvé
des choses quand même le retard en
matière de lutte contre la pollution et
grands même si depuis quelques années
les municipalités pour des efforts dans
les alpes-maritimes cellule
d'intervention contre la pollution
control régulièrement les 40 kilomètres
de plages les actions qui permettent de
savoir mais qui perd maintenant
d'empêcher exemple cette plage de vie
france déconseillé à la baignade
puisque le seuil de pollution toléré et
dépasser les normes administratives
c'est plus de 2000 germe appelé
escherich acolyte vincent you tube et
plus de 1000 gère ma tristesse cofreco à
100 cm qu'est ce que risquent ces
enfants ces personnes évident que ces
personnes et ces enfants risquent un
certain nombre d'infections aux tic
conjonctivite ou hépatiques batik viral
sur vous êtes médecin est ce que vous
voyez beaucoup de patients atteints de
conjonctivite de type n'était au fond
rien depuis un mois
on peut dire qu'une dizaine de malades
par jour se présente à mon cabinet pour
clore de conjonctivite de kératite
manifeste manifestement en rapport avec
la peña les risques existent donc mais
il ne faut pas les exagérer début
juillet plus de 90% des plages testé
était selon les mairies de bonne qualité
quoi qu'il en soit la limpidité de l'eau
l'absence d'un grand gâchis qu'on n'en
mesure pas laisse bien souvent à désirer
les équipements de prévention aussi
seulement deux stations d'épuration dans
les alpes-maritimes
actuellement il en existerait de recel
de cagnes sur mer et celle de cannes
il en est un autre deux autres qui n'ont
l'exécution va commencer cette année
celle de vallauris san de cap 3000 et
d'autres sont en projet à très brève
échéance telle celle de mon temps à
cette heure c'est la solution de penser
c'est une des solutions à nice ce projet
qui coûte cher plusieurs milliards de
centimes se réalisera peut-être en 85
des sceaux si les impératifs de gestion
imposer d'autres choix
la chasse au gaspi elle va bien 31% des
français
environ 4 millions 700 mille personnes
ont décidé de modifier leur comportement
général de conducteurs depuis
l'ouverture de la campagne
c'est ce qu'a dit monsieur vivien chef
de service de la chance pour les
économies des airs
selon lui si tous ces automobilistes
continuent et level méthodes de conduite
l'économie serait de 4 123 mille tonnes
équivalent pétrole par an maison que
dit-il faire encore mieux ce n'est pas
seulement en occident mais aussi en
europe de l'est ce que le ravitaillement
il semble bien difficile but le
gouvernement de bucarest vient de
décider que les touristes qui vont en
roumanie devraient désormais acheter
leur essence ans de mise en devises
occidentales et cette mesure gildas
morvan et touristes français puisque le
franc fait justement partie des deux
accepté en revanche de nombreux hongrois
que le slovaque polonais etc
séjournant actuellement
ce groove campagne en panne sèche parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu de devises fortes
je vous rappelle que la roumanie apporte
son pétrole d'iran et que parmi ces deux
fournisseurs figurent également de
l'urss
or l'union soviétique réduite à
convenance et fournitures aux pays de
l'europe de l'est parce qu'elle craint à
terme de manque et elle même de pétrin
monsieur georges marchais bien de
rentrer à paris après des vacances
passées à lui de sa vie comme il en a
l'habitude il a conduit les journalistes
dès son retour et il leur a donné les
appréciations du parti communiste
français à propos de la politique
économique et sociale du gouvernement
monsieur marchait paraît n'avoir rien
perdu de son punch et bien entendu avec
sa mère le bouquet georges marchais a
traité de nombreux sujets au cours de
cet entretien de rentrée ses vacances en
yougoslavie ou la politique n'a pas ou
peu absent puisqu'il a rencontré le
chapiteau les réflexions d'autres moyens
monsieur marchait dénonce la campagne
contre le vietnam fait dit il parce
qu'ils se taisaient au moment du martyr
du peuple de snipers sont atroces et
rassurez vous pour la pandémie au
parlement européen quand ce sera
important j'y serai de toute façon dit
il
la direction du parti communiste et
collégial la nouvelle droite
une décision qui monsieur marché pour
cacher les vrais problèmes économiques
et sociaux qui ont constitué justement
l'essentiel de ses propos de cet appât
nique les français dit georges marchais
se souviendront de cet été 79 où je le
cite les surgissent carré bat son plein
gré à une véritable agression contre le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs et le
parti communiste a décidé de répliquer
immédiatement
d'ailleurs dit-il le récent succès
obtenu par les dockers après 27 jours de
grève prouve que la lutte pour être
efficace alors le parti communiste
défini neuf objectifs de lutte 9e
édition visant à annuler les récentes
mesures prises par le gouvernement
il s'agit du blocage des prix des
services et des loyers pendant six mois
et du rétablissement du compte leur
départ
du relèvement dessous les bas salaires
et des retraites et du lard et de
l'arrêt du licenciement dans les
entreprises du relèvement du pouvoir
d'achat des paysans de la majoration des
allocations familiales et de la prime de
transport
enfin le parti communiste réclament la
réduction de la taxe sur les carburants
la taxation des profits réalisés par la
compagnie pétrolière et on appris dans
les capitales également un impôt sur les
heureux ce n'est pas un programme conclu
monsieur marché ce sont des objectifs
pour lesquels les communistes vont se
mobiliser avec à leur tête un georges
marchais qui promet aux gouvernements de
durs moments nous regardons monsieur
marché
soyez pas un création me lis je suis là
en bonne santé en pleine forme et croyez
moi
d'ailleurs le petit exposé que je viens
de vous faire j'ai voulu seulement
traiter des problèmes économiques et
sociaux monde que vous pouvez vous
attendre à un parti communiste
extraits on ne fera que poursuivre en
améliorant mais à parti communiste
extrêmement combatif j'ajoute
extrêmement dur parce que je considère
qu'avec le pouvoir à quand le feu de
pouvoir sans aucun doute le plus
réactionnaire de plus anti démocratique
le plus anti national que nous ayons
connue il est nécessaire de développer
fermement sur le terrain de classe une
lutte acharnée pour la défense des
intérêts des travailleurs et en premier
lieu des plus défavorisés par conséquent
dans la période qui commence à partir
d'aujourd'hui on en compte quand même
qui a le mois d'aout les vacances et les
fermetures d'entreprises
mais vous pouvez
faire confiance le secrétaire général du
parti comme tous les communistes sera au
premier rang sur le de l'adulte et jeu
complet on pouvoir de mauvais moment
pour lui nous entrerons
incontestablement sens aux granulés
groupe ouvrira demain auront lieu les
élections à l'assemblée constituante or
plusieurs leaders connu préconise matin
devant le côté ces élections comme le
pense et si le front national une
formation politique en compte
c'est à dire grosso modo les héritiers
du docteur mossadegh
celui là même qui avait failli renverser
le chah en 1952 alors pourquoi ce
boycott parce qu'il juge que la vie
politique actuelle en iran donne une
trop grande prépondérance aux leaders
religieux et ce au moment même où
l'ayatollah khomeini annonce qu'il sera
candidat à la présidence de la
république
décision prise par constater dit il
divers courants tentait de faire échec à
la révolution et le reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux en iran philippe rochot
alain pagano montre à quel point le
mouvement religieux entend imposer sa
loi dans la politique iranienne
à
un million de manifestants dans les
repères pour la première fois depuis son
retour l'ayatollah khomeiny a battu le
rappel de ses partisans pour montrer
qu'il avait toujours le pays derrière
lui et pour prouver qu'il avait aussi
l'appui de l'armée
daffé survolé la capitale pourtant les
fantômes de l'aviation iranienne
démonstration de force menace à peine
voilée contre les minorités qui
contestent la république islamique est
sévère avertissement à toute opposition
intérieure
plus que jamais c'est l'ordre moral des
religieux qui règne à téhéran les
gardiens de la révolution sont bien
décidés à empêcher les mouvements laïcs
reprendre pied dans la grille polycopiés
brière aujourd'hui encore c'est une
majorité écrasante qui demandent l'
islamisation total les rejette toute
forme de démocratie à l'occidentale
c'est ce qui arrive compliqué encore une
assembler centralisée et
concentrationnaire à ce vieux
le mouvement laïque ne fait pas le poids
dans un cimetière de téhéran où il a pu
compter ses partisans pour la première
fois les iraniens étaient autorisés à
rendre hommage aux 800 morts des émules
de 52 hommage surtout à mossadegh
premier ministre d'alors qui nationalise
aller pétrole d'iran est ébranlé le
pouvoir du chat il est resté cher au
coeur des iraniens mais personne n'a
vraiment relever le flambeau
tant m ce fils qui nous a confié que la
politique était trop dangereuse en
erreur
qui
aujourd'hui les partisans de mossadegh
n'ose pas s'attaquer au pouvoir
religieux et se contente de faire
campagne pour l'indépendance nationale
les américains est aussi et empêcher les
russes qui sont en train de s'infiltrer
dans le monde
il faut avoir une planque pour lutter
contre l union soviétique pour empêcher
l'union soviétique de 2,2 prend la place
de des américains aux nues
le nom de mossadegh était pourtant le
symbole derrière lequel les laïcs aurait
pu s'organiser face aux religieux
aujourd'hui ils ont perdu la partie
à tel point qu'on se demande si le
mouvement laïque encore droit à la
parole il a droit mais il ne peut pas
parce que ben le mouvement religieux est
si fort et c'est ça ça va compter n'est
ce pas entre 20 millions de partisans de
momar à lisieux et peugeot 1 million de
partisans des front national et les
autres groupes
ça marche pas comme ça parce que c'est
majorité la preuve de la volonté des
religieux d'écraser le mouvement laïque
nous allions l'avoir lors de cet hommage
à mossadegh organisée par le front
national
pathé
au moment où les militants sendin
salliot mossadegh symbole de liberté et
d'indépendance
les partisans de l'ayatollah khomeini
faisait rupture dans la manifestation
les leaders du front national n'ont pas
pu parler paralysé par les religieux ils
ont décidé de ne présenter aucun
candidat aux élections
les hommes de l'ayatollah khomeini sont
sûrs aujourd'hui de se tailler ainsi la
part du lion dans la future assemblée
constituante
en espagne jausiers le personnage de
l'etna tourisme a diminué dans les eaux
côtières de la province de gérone
c'est à dire au sud de perpignan 40 % de
moins que l'an dernier
et chose rarissime il y a dépassé nous
militons dans les hauteurs de la
caravane pourtant voici une nouvelle
assez réconfortant pour les vacanciers
l'organisation séparatiste basque eta
politico-militaire annonce qu'elle a
décidé d'arrêter sa campagne armée
l'organisation regrette les morts de
madrid qui sont tombés dimanche des
ruines victimes des explosions et elle
déclare je cite nous ne luttons et nous
ne lutteront jamais contre le peuple
espagnol avec lequel nous voulons une
alliance pour détruire l'ennemi par
c'est à dire l'état espagnol centraliste
à anglet pyrénées atlantiques
deux membres présumés de l'êta ont été
victime cet après-midi dans la fente à
la grave coup de théâtre politique en
italie monsieur cantaluppi
démocrate-chrétien croyait avoir réussi
à constituer un ministère après plus de
six mois de crise gouvernementale et
c'est au moment même où il présentait
service au président de la république
monsieur pertini qu'il a appris par des
dépêches d'agencé de presse la décision
totalement inattendue pour lui les
socialistes de voter contre le
gouvernement espère qu il éprouve à luri
g c'est donc au palais du quirinal dans
le bureau même du chef de l'état comme
ce panel fille a pris la décision de
renoncer à la tâche le président de la
république a confié à monsieur k sig le
soin de constituer une ministère sega si
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur du
gouvernement de haïti
occupant ce poste au moment de
l'enlèvement de m et aldo moro
il est assez curieusement un cousin de
monsieur girling guerre puisque à terre
général du bas rhin que m
il compte aller très vite et réussi des
incendies de forêt en ardèche dans la
nuit les avions canadair intervenir plus
faire entreprises
ce matin dans l'arrière-pays niçois du
sram nouvelle flambée 100 hectares
détruits en revanche l'ensemble de
pierrefeu et les maîtriser mais
l'irlande ont ravagé quelque 12 cents
hectares dans une lettre à monsieur
barnes et gaston defferre maire de
marseille et plaindre de ces régionales
provence côte d'azur demande que soient
prises des dispositions indispensables
pour enrayer ces incendies de forêt et
que l'on pense à prévoir au budget de 80
les sommes indispensables pour monsieur
de faire les mesures annoncées par
l'administration il ya quelques jours à
son époux est insuffisante
ils demandent entre autres que l'on
double la flotte de 12 canadair
actuellement en service
le tiff en espoirs a balayé hong kong ce
matin avec des vents atteignant le 16
blessés ont été conduits à l'hôpital
dans la première heure qui a suivi
l'arrivée du typhon
débattons dérapé sur leur ventre dans le
port les voitures sont écrasées sur les
arbres abattus et de nombreuses
personnes ont dû être évacuées de leur
demeure sur les collines dominant hong
kong en raison du danger d'éboulement à
l'aéroport 40 vols avaient été annulés
nous sans peine que l'odeur vous en
prendrez les bâtiments quant à la ville
et bien ma foi poids soufflé par le
typhon accident sur les autoroutes des
panneaux de signalisation et des objets
variés paulhan dans toutes les
directions
l'innovation routes bloquées par des
arbres des récits voler la réalisation
du vieux rêve déclic à rethel possible
réponse en direct sur antenne 2 le maroc
c'est à dire le samedi 11 où il ne
s'agit pas d'une légende mais des
championnats du monde de vol libre de
saint-hilaire du touvet près d'être
éteint
ils ne seront plus que 50 à voler à
l'issue des éliminatoires
et parmi eux sept tomes audace suprême
qui se prononce pour un oiseau a donc
pris des ailes du souffle et de
l'altitude
mais petite revanche car il faut bien
que la nature ne perdent pas tous ses
droits
chaque homme doit en effet porté sa
croix ou bien aller à sa rencontre
deuxième rappelle ici que l'on n'est
souvent qu'un drôle d'oiseau
troisième figure pour ne pas perdre la
face si l'aigle assistent au spectacle
de loin l'homme et les multiples ici son
exploit ou mieux ils se multiplient et
ils sont multi qui vont d'ailleurs sur
antenne ne les samedi 11 et lundi 13 en
direct dans star était hier c'est
aujourd'hui le premier de la saison
domine était réservé aux hommes est
gagnante à la fin du héros cinq
appartenant à la gamme quand entraînée
par matt est monté par saint martin 2e
peuvent choquer le 8 3e quart temps des
4e vont donc arriver 5 8 4 la
combinaison gagnante figuraient quoique
sans offre permet des pronostics de
pierrette brès et vous avez dit ce que
j'avais pu gagner dans l'ordre ou dans
l'ordre 1 2175 ou 435
si vous avez suivi ou améliorer ses
promesses tout à l'heure c'est hervé
claude guibert comme fraiseur vous
présentera l'addition
demain daniel vidal vient de présenter
en 2010 nous nous retrouvons s'il est
bien de mal à mater les céleris im de
mozart dont je vais vous parler
maintenant parce qu'il ouvre demain le
festival d'orange dans une
interprétation du nouvel orchestre
philharmonique conduit par petermann en
avant première je vous propose pour
terminer ce jour mal en musique puis un
extrait de ce célèbre requiem quand n2
transmettra intégralement de 23 ou les
mélomanes savent chaîne a décidé
d'organiser pendant les vacances des
soirées musicales chaque jeudi et par
exemple ils pourront écouter ce soir la
messe en si mineur de jean sébastien
bach interprétées par l'orchestré
philharmonique beline que dirigeant
jean-claude présence pour l'heure donc
le requiem de mozart au festival
d'orange
bonsoir merci
ans
et
à
vva
en tout
et
en novembre